- hello one and all to the h3 podcast
transcendental moment it's a moment
there's no longer an experience it's
just a moment fleeting as it may be a
terrific moment and one that we will all
cherish today's moment is sponsored by
figs Fitch and Thor - I told you is
gonna be a stick what did I say big
stitch man stitch fix and door - this is
gonna be one of those episodes where
everyone's like I'm just gonna give a
huge disclaimer at the top this episode
is just give me one of those episodes
because we're on no-sleep no-sleep Jerry
to quote the great sign for Kramer from
Seinfeld so just give me one of those
episodes so I don't know what to tell
you guys other than that so buckle up
because this is full delirium regula
that's right
well people are gonna be like oh they
have a kid or something nein we were up
- well that's part of it yes oh we do
have a kid right why did I wake up at
6:00 right that's your problem I have a
problem on the other end is that I
couldn't fall asleep because I was
watching Temptation Island which is a
reality show that Ian got me hooked on
and it's like like all good reality TV
shows in my opinion you hate it you hate
watch it yeah I always think that that's
the only way to watch it but I guess
some people actually love it well when I
see like the bachelor finale and you see
all these women like clutching their
pearls and they're all invested
emotionally I was like dude there's
actually people watching this on
ironically I just assumed they're like I
think it's fifth part of the show right
there I paid actors Sade I think it's
got to be 50/50 maybe but this shows so
bad dude like I don't know who signs up
for this [ __ ] I mean I really don't they
bring a couple to an island they
separate them there's four couples so
the guys go in one hotel and the girls
go in the other and then they bring all
these like these singles to try to
to tempt them to cheat on their partner
and so first of all the singles that
they recruit are like the sloppiest
drunkest third pathetic thirstiest
people bro I'm telling you this one girl
got like blackout drunk the first night
and was trying to sleep with all
different for the guys like she would go
up and be like I just I'm so into you
like you all for the guys I'll oh my god
this girl dude like they must have gone
on her Instagram and just looked and
just saw what a mess she was and how
sloppy drunk she wasn't me like she's
perfect and they're just giving them I
told Ella I was like this this shows
like Nazi concentration camp guards they
just keep them drunk all the time cookie
what the the trauma everybody don't do
all the time so I don't understand it
but I love it too
I don't want it to seem like you're the
only one want to know we love it yeah I
had to pause it because I was like ela
should i when she was falling asleep I
was like I should pause this right and
she goes this is good contact we're
gonna have to save this and she's right
the part that's so messed up about this
show is that everyone's trying their
best to be good well one guy broke on
the second episode but we expected that
everyone's trying to be so good and
faithful and then and then the spouse
comes to a bonfire at the end and they
cherry-pick clips to make it look as bad
as possible and then try to lead on the
other person that the spouse is like
yeah totally cheating on them and they
make each other watch what the other one
is doing and it's very cruel it's very
very cruel and borderline I think it's
immoral to be honest I don't know why
you would put yourself through it
because the couples choose to go on the
show that's like a that's like a Jew
checking into a concentration to
continue the guard analogy just go like
do you have any vacancies here but did I
say something racist already I mean well
I get a pat I get it you're Jewish it's
a little racy though to be making
concentration-camp jokes this early in
the show yeah
on American mm-hmm maybe on YouTube
Aryan mm-hmm but it's is borderline
immoral because um these people have
been together for like ten years you
know what they're idiots they're on the
show what but the way that they cherry
pick the clips and then they start
messing with their heads and then they
get all insecure and crazy and then you
know when you get your heart broken and
you get anxious and you start feeling
insecure and relationship is that your
awful feeling and then it makes you act
irrationally and then they get you drunk
and they make you feel insecure and
anxious they're torturing these people
man it's awesome ten stars I like it
anyway uh out well let's get let's
talking about other [ __ ] you know but
you'll had to wake up at 6:00 and I
couldn't sleep we have a problem where
we are so used to going to sleep late
that we still haven't changed that and
theater wakes up at 6:00 no matter what
and we are up until like 2:30 at minimum
I don't really go all the big what I do
the night shift because he often wakes
up in the middle of the night yeah
though I'm on that shift but now we
don't have that shift and it happens
sometimes but in a way where we got to
go to sleep early I can't do it I can
not I I wish that I could go to bed at
8:00 it's my time to do everything like
I wait all day and then at night I do
everything work
I draw if I need to like it's all
happening at night I eat right showers
we don't have a life once during the day
we have no life
Theodore goes to bed at like 6 5 or 6
o'clock and then between that after that
hour is the only time we get a lot to
have any kind of life and before that
we're working non-stop and then we get
home and we usually have more work to do
after he goes to bed and so we only get
to sit down and watch TV at like 12 yeah
and then that's sentation island and
then your two episodes deep but all of a
sudden you got to see what's going to
happen poor us we have a perfect life
ela how dare you complain I'm not
complaining I'm just sharing where we're
at
we're sharing that's what I was just
echoing what everyone we're thinking
listen to these mother effers complain
I'm not complaining he's a professional
because he's so sweetie and is an angel
boy it's so easy now compared to our
beginning the beginning was tough brutal
and now it's all way way way easier he
started to make like little signs like
he's talking he goes like usually he's
just yelling and stuff and grunting but
then he starts to actually use like his
voice yeah and it's so cute the little
kid voice he goes it's like just the
cutest most feared thing he's the best
he's so cute
we start to dress him he's got like a
little bomber jacket my mom just bought
him look at this I just saw okay tell me
would he make this man I was cracking up
cuz I just didn't expect it homie lights
like a taco on fire so I don't know what
it is but you know you're supposed to
put the fire out before you put
something in your mouth to watch this
well her throne she walks off oh she
seems like she was finally she's fine
right but like what are we doing here
what's happening well the way that she
did walks off like all right thank you
bye and the way he shoved it in her
goddamn the back of her throat
presumably to extinguish the flame hmm
I think I mean I'm sure that's why he
did it but that's gotta burn your mouth
no yeah I mean I get burned from my good
soup no mmm yeah
what did where are they look at the back
there's like there's just an somewhere
to us dude you know what my fantasy is
to have some weird some dirty street
vendor shove his fingers in my mouth
that's my fantasy that's how I die I've
seen the future that's how I die oh we
have some interesting stats as you guys
know the h3h3 shop is back open for
business h3h3 shop comm revving a little
competition here in the office each one
of us has our
own custom shirt and we were curious we
took a poll last time we talked about it
wondering who would sell the most shirts
will we have the stats available the
shirts are available throughout the rest
of the week for purchase to get it in
time for the holidays which is great
news we are splitting it five ways with
all the cast member sees for everyone
here we can when is that time the day
that I can order by to get it for
Christmas I think they said the tenth
right Ian yeah
how great is that perfect that's a whole
week from now from from the third the
tenth you know they do the math right 7
plus 3 10 very good thank you very much
so nd and ela as we all predicted was
number one she's crushing it with 400
sales so congratulations to you
thank how does that feel it's really
it's not me I think it's a we did the
design I think he's the guy that's
winning really well but he made this
ones in there not selling [ __ ]
Ian's who made hands hey Dean's in last
place
what the hell which shocked me big that
really shocked me I'm like you only have
45 shirts in come on bro you're not
pulling your weight
yeah I'm not sharing the revenue with
your ass you only sold 45 shirts hold on
though it's out of the three of us which
we all knew ours was we're gonna sell
less Zach's is doing the back yeah way
we're gonna get into that again design
that one true ian is winning so this one
this one's a wild card
Zach of the 3d spelling the best eighty
that's double what Inns sold and Ian
made it though so I'm wondering do
people love Zach I know people love Zach
but is it that people love Zach more or
is it the design is awesome I think it's
the design is just so far because that
was all Ian Ian stepped in to take any
credit away from Zach but I think it's
the design but I said Ian I mean why are
you what why are you hiding these skills
away from us like this is someone that's
not cells Zach short either he's got
some charm people like people love Zach
well a new commodity on the blog that's
right great hair
oh thank you yeah that's true like Brad
some people say Zach I see in the
comments a lot of people say that
whenever you talk they feel like you're
trying to seduce them how do you feel
about that I mean I do have a sexy voice
is that what it is no I think that I
mean that that's partially I think what
they're saying is just the way you talk
is like someone being like hey baby what
you doing later
little Garth Brooks being raw yeah just
being raw just being you but some of
them want you here you can't unhear it
so say something like because when you
just said that I thought you were
putting on an act kind of like you're
trying to seduce me I'm fine how are you
I'm doing what are you doing I'm doing
fine how are you doing all right well
yeah it said sound like sex trying to
seduce me
yeah mm-hmm damn nobody says [ __ ] like
that about me man I'd be an insult
without you yo I like to throw that out
there
so congratulations Zack I do think this
is a bacchanal version over in cell no
because I feel like women ultimately
chauvinistic
I feel like ultimately that's a very
I'll go ahead dan I don't want to speak
out of turn well in in cell is a
gender-neutral term just music
voluntarily have you ever met or heard
of a female in sobre I suppose no
they're out there they're out I never
hurts here i won you would you you know
it's funny you match a female and male
and sell they'll be so repulsed by each
other they would never want to have sex
with each other or there will be a
perfect man no until they are not a
perfect match for anybody oh I shouldn't
say that
I love the insoles they're sweet people
oh yeah not only are there in cells I
just googled it they have their own term
called
sells I knew it there you go can you see
any pictures of them what do they look
like
does that mean anything they look like
they'll show my street ball them them
sell stop what you guys acting like I'm
crazy like I want to know what the FEM
cells look like stop with this [ __ ] let
me see I just want to show pornograph
pornography a famous bro I don't think
any real picture of a real person okay
Dan so get out here I can see your
screen there are people but it's a lab
it Oh like this
celibate means not having sex okay so
Deus I mean that's a femme so I mean I'm
not trying I don't know maybe I
shouldn't show this but you get the idea
what it looks like a dateable girl to me
okay let's stop you know what I mean we
don't need we're talking about Zach's
sultry voice let's get back well top
thank you I appreciate bypass you're
welcome you're welcome
so Ian was in last dan was in second to
last 56 honestly so there you have it
Ian I mean wow I thought yours was gonna
come in stronger than that I mean to
wait on you dancing on when she was dude
right I see I thought mine was gonna be
the last or second and I was right I
hate competitions though it is why I
like drama it makes me like feel bad 150
baby me shallow everybody I can't wait
to see someone actually wearing this
it's [ __ ] ridiculous hello everybody
and of course ela is the winner so so
high that is so strange about Ian's
shirt I really maybe I don't know if you
guys are listening you want to step up
for an I think this is a good one maybe
it's just I think the prop here's the
problem it's a bunch of dudes watching
the show hmm nobody wants to walk around
the picture why I think that's this
because it's it is kind of yeah very
kind of gay to walk around with this
shirt as a dude if your bank it's bald
if I think if your mega masculine like
me and it says I got a piece so bad
yeah that seems like a fetish sure
you're going to be masculine you just
need to know that you can pull it off
and you can I can't I got a piece so bad
well let's see you guys step it up for
these guys because if they don't sell at
least 100 they're cut out of the the cut
out of the world that wasn't the rule
they gotta sell least 100 or the cut out
you get nothing
no I'm kidding of course I'm kidding
come on we love the interns we have no
interns here so that was interesting
guys we had I had a lot of hate from the
last episode the last episode was the
Thanksgiving special you laugh you lose
I thought it was a lot of fun I enjoyed
doing it I heard you guys to go enjoy it
the whole cast was out here and we were
trying to make each other laugh what did
people think about it that people liked
it all I heard was people slamming me I
didn't actually see any reviews of the
episode itself but here I have some
comments cuz I thought it was pretty
funny that by the way I I thought I was
choosing some really classic these are
videos that make me laugh that I like
and everyone was saying you know and
they're very short too so I says even
watch the video he doesn't laugh I go
wash it again could you all you're kind
of cheating but it worked I got him to
giggle so you know I'm trying to put on
the show here but apparently it didn't
play well with the audience
they said Ethan ruined it and I'm only
12 minutes in mm-hmm you tried getting
them to laugh by replaying it so much
all cuz he chose bad memes how dare you
watch your profanity
that's a classic Jackson Ethan this is a
deep cut Ethan plays a clip that is
literally every single you left me fail
cringe at any right well I don't watch
that [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay for me it's a classic I as far when
I found this video 12 years ago I was
the only person that knew about it does
that make me a boo
maybe but at the time I was a I was a
trailblazer was I not can I be honest
Shh maybe not okay
I was a little tiny bit disappointed
that it was all clips that I knew mmm
so I think in the future we gotta set
rules the way that you entered sounds
like you were more than this then a tiny
bit disappointed no I'm just trying to
not come off and go hard you all right
that was a big time disappointing you
are massaging my fragile ego I I'm
trying to work on not being too harsh
because I I have a harsh you rule thing
going on right now yeah first thing what
does that mean I'm trying to I don't
know hmm let's unpack that well I work
with people mm-hmm and you we work on
Teddy fresh which the creative process
can be hard to like work with people and
still like I don't know I
you got a you got a do it things nicely
and not like get people turned off by
being I I don't know I wasn't prepared
to talk about this okay well you know we
got a I saw an opening there do to
explore some that I'm trying to work on
some things so that's what you're saying
if I kind of help you unpack it is that
you have a tendency to deliver your
comments maybe more harshly than you
would wish yeah and you're afraid that
it could be affecting the morale of your
employees exactly yes and so I mean it's
a real problem when you're in a material
position and it's hard to give people
comments and not demoralize them right
yeah exactly
well you failed on me I feel awful after
your comments though certainly knew
maybe so that's that's the new problem
even if I try to be subtle I can't
really I wasn't really upset I don't
know how you do that I think it's really
just I don't know I really don't know
what's the solution of that cuz part of
it is like I don't know
you know yeah it's learning process
because sometimes there is definitely a
reason to what I'm thinking and I know
that I'm passionate about something for
a reason and at the end of the day I
need to be true to what I'm thinking and
like follow that intuition that I have
but sometimes you gotta also be flexible
so you have to make maybe sometimes
right balance maybe sometimes you I'm
not talking about you I'm talking and
you know the editorial you is that
sometimes you need to pick your battles
I guess is what I'm trying to say yeah
is that it's something you can let slide
you don't want to Nick pick something
everything somebody does yeah all right
but I but you know maybe you do right
right right I don't know this is a deep
cut no well I have bigger problems
people everyone here on the TV's
shit-talking me no one laughs Ethan are
you laughing nobody laughs Ethan hold up
let me play it again Ethan let's try out
I try not to left challenge also Ethan
gets offended with no one's laughing
Ethan's like a kid where if something
bad is about to happen he changes the
rules Ethan I honestly don't know if I'm
gonna laugh at any proceed to laugh at
every single [ __ ] Ethan get this off
the screen before I laugh also East and
plays the video ten times
Ethan's boomer humor really showed this
episode
he's gonna be the worst play cards
against humanity with come on guys it's
funny listen again
Ethan already has dad humor old-ass
memes and playing the video enzymes Wow
ruff
I've been eviscerated but regardless I
had fun I enjoyed it I I was just trying
to be competitive you know I was trying
to get Dan to eat mayonnaise like that
was for me the ultimate objective of the
of the episode I think it's because
you're so focused on creating
entertaining Thank You content thank you
that's what I care about that's all I
care about I'm here to entertain you
guys I'm here to make a great show and
if I come off as a Boomer which I do
find it to be quite derogatory and
basically calling me the N word then
it's only because I want to entertain
you so badly so he's a Boomer equivalent
to Fred oh do you think boomer
definitely on the on the on the
derogatory scale of fredo actually if
I'm being honest I think Fredo might be
even more offensive than boomer really
yeah I see more people getting offended
at boomer lately because right oh yeah
but they're wrong because boomer afraid
oh is it specifically Italian so if you
go to an Italian you go you Fredo it's
like you know you're it's a it's a
racial slur in that it's targeting at
times is it offensive
I mean it's reference to boomer is
boomers yeah but it's everybody's a
boomer and also boomers used to
everyone's just a boomer if you
understand like the people who are
actually getting butthurt at being
called a boomer don't understand that
everybody's a boomer this is a scale you
know they say that everybody's gay it's
just like a spectrum it's a scale of how
gay you are you've heard that they say
that I'm like a I'm like a I'm like a
4.9 boomer the gays on the gay scale
question no I'm kidding I don't know
what I don't know who measures these
things I'm like Dan I'm like point I'm a
fraction away from being gay
just under the mark but on the boomer
scale is the same it's a spectrum like
autism it's a spectrum okay and so you
can be a wine on the Boomer scar you
could be a hundred on the Boomer scale
for example let me show you a Boomer
watch me in the last episode oh let me
show you a Boomer like a hi let me go to
my Twitter account today because I Steve
made a real Boomer move like this is
like a 95 on the Boomer scale he goes he
goes what the [ __ ] is a Boomer so I was
like dude if you have to ask you're
probably a Boomer right which is at
which the response itself is somewhat
Boomer you see what I'm saying I'm glad
you follow it's stupid so I'm gonna
issue I am here to issue an apology for
my boomer behavior for my comments to
boomer so I'm gonna walk over into the
podium room which we've set up for the
purpose of issuing apologies to our our
loyal fans so I will hop over to the
podium room now interesting it's a
pretty boomer thing to do how's the
audio I want you to I want you to
capture all this is an important moment
we have brought in this podium because
there's a lot of there's been a lot of
apologies being issued lately
and I feel that we it was appropriate to
bring out an apology podium a somber
place a sober place a place of
reflection quiet reflection and
soul-searching where we can issue the
most deepest and heartfelt apologies to
anyone who who was offended or made even
a little bit uncomfortable by anything
we said because that's totally never our
intentions here on the HTTP podcast the
greatest show in the world ever made by
far
so anyway I've made I made jokes I made
a lot of people
I played videos many two times I made a
lot of bad memes and jokes here many
people have been references me to A to B
I've been a Boomer I even called ice-t a
Boomer and I mean it takes one to know
one
so can you apologize for being a Boomer
I don't know I apologize what am i post
apologize for and making anyone
comfortable with bad jokes I apologize
for not following the rules not
following the rules ela chimed in from
the other room thank you
I apologize to my cleaning lady who I
left a giant [ __ ] streak in the toilet
on the way out I know she's gonna have
to clean well you know like a streak
down the side of the toilet bowl you
don't know what I'm talking about that's
the problem
I apologize for are you even ever what
you don't leave [ __ ] streaks in the toy
people understand only boomers dude why
you shocked by that it just came out of
nowhere
okay well apologies you know apologize
for surprising them all Jesus for
surprising damn I apologize too
[Music]
I apologize to my dad I used to take
still leftovers from him and he gets so
pissed at me like way too pissed at me
kind of gave me a complex he'd be like
dude who ate my [ __ ] burrito and I'd
be like maybe if you actually made food
that I want to eat I won't eat your
[ __ ] leftovers dad that's not really
an employee if you actually love me and
spend time with me and wouldn't even be
an issue and I'll respect your authority
more I don't think you can complain on
the apology booth I'm losing track of
the uh let me get back back on track
I apologize for the bad jokes and and I
you know I look forward to coming here
and making more statements in the future
and not just me any I think these guys
have a lot team Ethan we lost your
microphone did you turn it off he got
caught off he's out anyways there's a
time limit
apologies can't go on for too long we
have a built-in mechanism to shut the
mic on when the apologies go for too
long so what did you think about the
done I like it I think um it's gonna
become very useful so you can't wait to
choose one else probably gonna need it
like once an episode all right well I
feel a little tender are we close to a
break here down tender I may need to
like clean myself up after that
emotional is dead seriously leaving me
in the trenches right now dead air I'm I
was putting everything away yeah we're
one minute away these guys never jump in
when they see me I spell an apology how
do you why does no one jump in when I
don't know you guys tell me you looking
over me like oh what's going on here
I'm switching I'm looking at the
computer mm-hmm do they know when to
break though Dan nobody's not near the
mic now let me ask you this Dan do you
think it's
do you think it is urgent to start
cleaning things up while the show is
live
I was just putting the microphone away
yeah man seeing why it died I guess that
is urgent I think I'm gonna itch I'm
gonna need an apology from you from all
of you
we'll have to do it after the break cuz
it is break time well we gotta have to
go to break I'm gonna clean myself up
I'm gonna wipe my tears away and we will
be right back to talk about the actual
stuff that we came here to talk about an
HP podcast greatest shows ever made
after this short commercial word from
our sponsors
look gentlemen there's an issue okay
we've grown up and we still need to put
on coal we have to dress ourselves
here's the problem I don't know what I
even like I don't even know what size I
am I frankly don't even know where to go
that's where stitch fix comes in because
you're probably clueless and pathetic
loser like me fat unhealthy I could very
well be single I should be single by all
measures of expectancy of you may well
be single here's where stitch fix comes
in they're gonna help you look
sophisticated look good and get up get a
girl do because nobody wants to dress us
good data Sulabh like you know uh a
white shirt with spaghetti stains on it
and ribs I mean nobody wants that here's
what stitch fixes it's an online
personal styling service that delivers
your favorite clothing brands right to
your door to get started go to stitch
fix calm slash h3 answer some questions
about your preferred style and your
personal shopper will ship a box of
clothing shoes and accessories right to
your door what stitch fix everyone can
look their best
they have solutions for men women and
kids well that's just messed up kids
like did you can't even dress yourself
you five-year-old
no I'm kidding it's good for parents
kids all over the US and now the UK
there's no commitment required you only
pay for what you keep shipping exchanges
and returns are always free Plus this
$20 styling fee is automatically applied
towards anything you keep in your box
you'll never have to think about looking
good again with stitch fix here's what
we're gonna do to get started today with
stitch fix calm slash h3 go to that URL
stitch fix calm slashed h3 and you get
it to extra 25% off when you keep
everything in your box
that's stitch fix calm slash h3 stitch
fix calm slash h3
so many reasons to deliver food to you
okay may be that you're stuck at school
stuck in the office you want to treat
yourself so you're sick at home as I
went there day it's raining your mom
doesn't pack you lunches anymore your
ladies are focused on work these are all
legitimate reasons but here's the one
that I like the most I'm hungry I'm lazy
I want food and I'm not cooking and I
don't even have stuff in my house to
cook anyway let's be real that's why
we're ordering food from door - door -
does the it's the ultimate destination
they got everything on it door -
connects you to your favorite
restaurants in your city ordering is
easy open the door - app choose what you
want to eat and your food will be
delivered to you wherever you are not
only is your favorite pizza joint
already on door - but there are over
340,000 restaurants and 3300 cities so
you might just find a new favorite -
Buster with door-to-door delivery in all
50 states and canada order from your
favorite local go twos or choose from
your favorite national treasures they
said restaurants but I'm gonna say
treasures like Chipotle Wendy's
chick-fil-a or The Cheesecake Factory I
love getting the idea of getting
Cheesecake Factory deliver your house
it's like an IV of calories brah just
straight home to you baby you no longer
need to leave the house to get heart
disease Cheesecake Factory don't worry
about dinner let dinner come to you with
door - right now our listeners can get
five dollars off their first order of 15
dollars or more when you download the
door - app and enter the promo code h3
did I say five dollars of free money
towards a delicious meal
yes I did five dollars off your first
order when you download the door - app
from the App Store and enter promo code
h3 let me tell you that one more time
because they're making me do it
don't forget that's a promo code h3 for
five dollars off your first order from
door - alrighty thank you
welcome back everybody trying to
surprise you a little bit keep you on
your toes
bet you didn't expect this shot but
thank you for sticking around that's it
that's all a gag how'd we do looking
good
that was great thank you let's talk uh
we did the pota meme album oh you
haven't Papa John baby I can't get
enough these Papa John memes in
reviewing the subreddit memes of the
week there's a fantastic Papa John memes
and a great follow up I hope your mom I
hope you're eating well since you moved
out me I've had over 40 pizzas the last
day you know that hits really close to
home for me because when I went to
college I weighed 130 and when I came
home I was like 200 bro
so Papa John looks like the guy in a
zombie movie that gets bit but tries to
hide it from the rest of the crew
this was my favorite this is so genius
dude oh my god it's the black.com
picture but Papa John with the pizzas
come on bro this I didn't get this great
value visibly damp 40 pizzas in 30 days
I mean what is the original product I've
loved the visibly damn have I said
something racist this isn't a very
flattering portrait of me and that you
are watching keith's any argue over what
white paint techniques they're gonna see
that I like well you guys are happy to
know there were a bidet family now so
the oh he's not gonna have a bidet in
his room that's pretty that's pretty
classy for a kid I think kids have a
shitty [ __ ] for a little bit before
he graduates to the bidet whatever what
was that this is the car that Elon
bought yes I love that he bought it for
um it's actually really interesting it's
the 1980s Ashton Mark Aston Martin
Bulldog concept car and this was the
basis I guess for a cyber truck yeah for
the cyber truck I love this one too it's
pretty crazy man how to eat 40 pizzas in
30 days
yeah we have 40 we have you 40 to 1 I
like those odds
hard pill to swallow the podcast
channels now the main channel I guess
for some that is a hard pill to swallow
I still refer to it as the podcast
channel you know I have not make no
comment on that that one surprised me so
then a fan sent out what look appears to
be Papa John's real true Instagram
account and this is breaking news
because this only has 92 followers on
Instagram and it's fantastic they're
like here's a picture here he is 17
likes at his Thanksgiving table with his
whole family we did a reversal that's a
big table
yeah dude he's got pizza money bro
billionaire you know he's got that place
of honor to look at him he's the only
one looking at the camera why is that so
by the way I was wondering if this is
bow I think it is isn't that crazy
is that bow it's his son his helpers
best friend bow but I remember he had
blond hair this guy is really but that
happens to kids yeah hmm maybe here's
another son I don't know but he looks
happy and I so I'm happy for both that's
him
but don't you find it amusing that him
and Beau are the only people looking at
the camera I mean that happens
infinitely all the others like someone
who's like hey I'm taking a picture no
one's paying attention shouldn't they be
eating pizza isn't that a little
hypocritical that Papa John's not eating
pizza for Thanksgiving very well anyway
we reversed search-engine this and this
doesn't exist anywhere so this is
exclusive [ __ ] bro this is Papa's real
account with 90 [ __ ] followers dude
here's his house look at that dude
that's pizza money whoa Dan find a table
design custom a dude that's a lot of
pizzas to sell it for a table like that
it doesn't do it do you like it I don't
know I've just
we just it looks like a dining room at a
restaurant look how much land he's got
good it makes me nervous cuz that means
you're hosting that many people yeah
he's not touching you didn't clean [ __ ]
probably got like 20 people catering I
know he lives on like a huge expanse
somewhere like in a Kentucky right is it
Kentucky you can get a lot of land there
yeah I think this farm cost like I don't
know like a hundred bucks or something I
kid the Kentuckians I love Kentucky but
this has got to be Papa's God is this
amazing you guys
92 followers the Papa John underscored
it's amazing it's not verified because I
remember we looked for awhile for him on
social media yeah because we wanted like
a way to maybe contact ID amped him
immediately I was like Papa hmm we'll
see let me see if it's red
let me check right now oh I've had over
40 pizzas in the last 30 days
what hero to even say that I've had no I
don't know if you read it I said hi mr.
Shatner is this really your account we
are huge fans and run a big show the
biggest show in the world a free podcast
you could hear on the streets yeah you
ask anyone ask your son Bo he knows this
we'd love to have you on to discuss your
side of the story and how the quality of
Papa John's has fallen to the wayside
which is true true I hope this message
finds you well you know you should tell
him that we ordered a pizza and it came
unsliced I got to pull up a picture of
that and I will get it that'll activate
him yeah can you pull up afterwards
let's I do want to send him that time
stamp be like papa
what's up the stock that's like
extortion he's like all right but
there's so much good footage here look
at look at him look at his styling bro
he's like a greaser Doug look at that
haircut did Dan I like it I like it I
like it I like it I didn't know her I
didn't realize I said that so much so
you guys started goofing on me with the
sound but I liked it I liked it
here here he's cooking a pizza in his
junk in his like own State
oh wait where's that video he's got a
link to V me love him cooking a pizza
and it's like his ranch no this is Fox
News interview god dammit that would be
on his story I believe oh is that the
story I can't watch that if I'm not
logged in Oh mmm but he you can see he's
got like this outdoor pizza oven on this
huge expanse of land looks like he owns
half a Kentucky anyway I thought that
was fascinating so I I mean I message I
think I may be the first person to DM
him on Instagram hopefully you knows how
that work that would be the best booking
ever after Ford Papa John 2 said right
here neck Brennan next to you across for
me what it feels like
I'll meet you but you gotta come here I
fly there yeah without hesitation did
I'd be like Papa's in the house dude
look at this that's from the episode air
yo they I'm that's Papa John they
delivered to that has never happened to
me my whole life to get on sly spy look
at this I'm telling you you gotta send
him that people are gonna call us like
they're gonna make they're gonna think
we requested it like that
no because it's just so unusual but we
didn't they literally just ship that to
us and huge bubbles are amateur to those
supposed to get rolled out pop has
taught me that in his insta stories
today he has a roller to get the bubbles
out they didn't do that clearly huh
amateurs oh my god and then I know oh I
forgot to mention I was watching
Temptation Island and it's this shows
very scandalous there's lots of thongs
it's very you could easily jerk off to
the show there's a lot of action but yet
this killed me bro they censored the
horses cause I was like yelled put it
back homies on a horse on a date and
they censored the horse's [ __ ] dude I
was like what
what does that mean about the viewing
audience I don't know is that
pornographic or horses [ __ ] like there
was a there was an internal debate at
USA by the producers and executives
about if to blur the sources [ __ ]
possibly even including the F staff the
FCC so I mean there's girls in thongs in
the same office there's girls in like a
lot tons of cleavage bro horses [ __ ] but
do you understand what that's it's
saying that people are that it's sexual
that it for it's too it's too graphic
the horse's [ __ ] you could see that at
the zoo but what it's saying is so weird
it's too pornographic I mean what about
any other dogs yeah I think the horse
was just really packing make you get out
the hell is like they brought you know
what happened because sometimes there
there there there dick isn't so crazy
like it comes and goes you know like
penises do and probably they had this
footage and they didn't realize at the
time that the horse was like packing big
time and he and when they were viewing
the footage like we can't show this the
horses dick is practically I'm dragging
on the ground
and so they decided to blur it but
that's just outrageous so there you go
this this is one other reason why the
show is amazing [ __ ] amazing I love
how you can still see that outline yeah
you can tell everything is just making
more curious
I wouldn't even notice the horses dick
until I was like was that blurred go
back of course and boy was it can oh
dude so I wrote to the fans
we watched mark McGrath made a cameo
breaking up and I put out the call I
said I love cameo I love everything
about cameo if you guys have any of
funny cameos I want to see him and
somebody delivered big-time this one
comes from Derrick he said I filmed a
video for my youtube channel where I had
people on cameo proposed to my
girlfriend for me request did one from
Sean Kingston for a hundred bucks
who was Sean Kingston Ian I didn't know
that was he's a musician he I'm trying
to think about his big song as I can't
think of it beautiful beautiful girls
Hammett beautiful girls keep going your
sultry voices you make me like my big
song I don't know I mean I don't
recognize it from I'm not saying you don
my beautiful voice I use well Sean
Kingston charged $100 and he proceeded
to accept the money and film a video of
him telling me that he can't do it
because it's an unusually larger fee for
for him to propose so he took the guy's
money to tell him that he needs more
money to propose that here's the video
it's [ __ ] awesome oh good for Derek
I'm really excited for you but we need
to pop the question I usually charge
more for stuff like that because that's
a different type of fee I can say
congratulations or something like that
but I feel like to ask the question
thank you contact you well thank you
guys for support and Lizzie [ __ ] do a
next video saying congrats or he wants
to buy a nylon hey wait what the
why yeah is he clowning on them why is
the floss what's with the floss is he
flexing that he flosses is that a flex
like I floss I use that floss it's
amazing I'm sure that floss is like
destroying the environment because it's
like it's this little piece of plastic
it's
because it's so good I love that floss
so much but it's kind of equals out cuz
i don't use baby wipes anymore so maybe
it's a ass whopper real and i stopped
eating meat so i could pull it a little
more you know what i'm saying it's
probably better for me to stop eating
meat than these low plastic cancers yeah
you know it's crazy they say that all
this plastic in the ocean like little
bits like that they start to get broken
down into micro plastics and the fish
eat it and you know it goes up the food
chain to us and these micro plastics are
like [ __ ] everybody up yeah i don't
know what's gonna happen with all this
stuff cuz it's just it's just like too
late for everything i don't know it's
too late baby now it's too late but we
really didn't [ __ ] the earth up
i love my little flosses but i can't not
use it i can't not use it you know that
song yeah girl king it's too late baby
i'll just stop using baby wipes come on
everybody i love was that good yeah i
like it so if you guys have any of the
cameos keep them coming that was amazing
he's like yo i didn't have a way to
message you so does it work can you not
just reject oh i'm sure here you can
reject he took the money
speaking of cameo though a video emerged
that i haven't seen in a long time
because we were talking about mark
McGrath so much I thought it was just
funny to give the context of the dude we
are dealing with off the charts but
always in your hearts mark McGrath you
went viral back in the day and I know I
know this is a Boomer video whatever but
it's related I think it's funny
mark McGrath slip eat someone called him
sugar gay which is hilarious by the way
should
ray sugar gay it was so funny especially
back then when that was during the time
when everyone's like oh that's Kate
that's gay this day but so he gets old
but her he's obviously drunk and
probably on other drugs that he wants to
fight this kid who's like looks like
he's like not even 18 was awesome
make a hole I'll beat your [ __ ] ass
okay I'm no talking make your [ __ ]
head
[Applause]
we know this mark McGrath deserves to be
called sugar gay everywhere pretty
violent
[Applause]
the business is real projecting the
tweezer nipples your nips but you know
it's you know marked wheezes his nipples
like you know he squeezes his nipples I
could watch this whole thing I'm going
to know yeah the kids not saying
anything is it I would have paid I would
have paid this good a thousand bucks on
sugar gay guys there's a huge audience
you know what what's happening is like
these restaurants in Beverly Hills on
the main strip there's always paparazzi
outside especially on the weekends just
waiting for celebrities to go in yeah I
recognize the street it's definitely
Beverly Hills and so he walks outside
drunk [ __ ] up on cocaine probably and
he's I think in his mind with cocaine
sourcing through his brain he thinks
he's being like outrageously
entertaining and he's up being a tough
guy and he's standing up for himself and
he's making this kid look like such a
fool and so do you see there's so many
cameras dude he's putting on a show man
there's like 50 people around it Prison
Rape this guy
I'll [ __ ] you in the ass he says you
give them a lot of attention I love how
he goes fanservice yeah no smile yeah
this is like the most nineties [ __ ] I
ever seen I love how it's all family up
there oh and then here he is trying to
[ __ ] some up there today is sugar gay
[ __ ] he is sold coke Ballack look at
that
dude he's hanging out so how long's he
hanging out brothers restaurant he loves
the camera never watched enough I mean I
liked it I liked it
the good thing over a couple of hits man
his life isn't ruined one minute it's
like dad at that how's it going every
morning's and Anna and then the next
minute it's like coked out in front of a
steakhouse in Beverly Hills ruining your
life
bigger gay in your hearts but off this
chart I thought it was fantastic I mean
I've never I don't know that I've ever
seen somebody's like mental
deterioration so perfectly encapsulated
in such a short clip because I feel like
that was him at his height I wonder like
who was recording it what is it for
there was tons of papa-paparazzi yeah
they always do that
they're always there at the specific
restaurants and the celebrities know
they're there and they go there to be
seen it's like a whole thing probably
their publicist even say hey go to my
Astro steakhouse the paparazzi are gonna
be there Saturday night and we want you
to be seen yeah and we told them you're
gonna be there so that look you know
it's totally like that bro 104 thousand
percent
I gotta get a publicist so I can get
some paparazzi to follow me around
people will do you think people will
click paparazzi videos of me yeah really
well I'd have to say something really
fantastic like listen didn't all I'm
saying is that the numbers were greatly
exaggerated was that about it's all it
cost me Heath in denies the Holocaust
outside Mastro steakhouse I'm not
denying it happened I'm just saying the
great the numbers were really yeah of
course I don't think that but you gotta
do something that's like a little bit of
a trial up with like a shirt with my
nips cut out see that's not good now
it's gotta be like sloppy a thin watery
nice life yeah I love to have a fight
and I like to hate you
that would get abused it yeah that'd be
awesome
you know like face banks and Alisa
whatever her names are having like a
public breakup right now yeah we should
do something like that we should
choreographic where I slap you God can
you imagine
I cannot that's not good press though
what if I came out with a fake baby and
I slammed it on the ground then it's
just a ring and they wouldn't care about
that yeah they want you don't
real Ian will you put will you come
outside and pretend to jump me and then
let me beat you up or something like
that touching this one
sure well which one is it are you
touching it or will you do it ah F -
you're easy I was waiting for the sound
bite - see if you can assume 90% of time
you hear me it's a sound bite is this
the sound bite this is all the sound
bite I'm not actually talking how do I
know I don't know what you're talking
anymore
I'm gonna go deep to be honest I don't
even know what I'm say say
supercalifragilistic as though she's
sewing I was talking the real Ian I hate
this candy
supercalifragilistic experience ound
bite that yeah but now do that we have
to go like they've written the levels of
Inception to make sure that I'm talking
to the real you I hate this candy so you
will pretend to beat me up yeah okay
thank you sure we should totally uh we
should that would be fun to orchestrate
some paparazzi video hmm it's gotta be
like people are gonna be worried for
your career when they see it so
Holocaust comment or like the n-word or
something yeah or like what that was but
what could someone say to me would set
me off
sugar gasps oh good boomer someone call
me a boomer who just called me a [ __ ]
boomer say that [ __ ] to my face [ __ ]
I'll choke your [ __ ] face I'm not
tough guy though hmm like Marcus Mark's
alpha male he's a totally an alpha male
all right let's move on I love mark
they'll shout out to sugar gay which is
honestly so fun and you can't be upset
by that
are you gonna offend gay people by it's
what the guy said it's funny I don't
think gay people it's so funny sugar gay
when we get on the podium it's funny
it's true okay wait now I'm questioning
everything but I was surprised dancing
back me up on the black people like
Popeyes things so maybe he'll back me up
on sugar gay being funny hmm
it's true - okay fine it's funny it's
funny that it triggered him so much I
mean I agree that is it's stupid I mean
so Trisha Paytas clique baited us and I
got excited you know I love putting her
into the thumbnail cuz it always drives
videos which I may still do by the way
we'll see she goes how I really feel
about the h3 podcast and she does it's a
18 minute video so I have made Zack
watch it obviously so wait is this a
podcast or a video well it looks like
she's promoting a podcast or something
I'm just skipping ahead but she I'm just
a blog she doesn't talk she doesn't end
up actually talking about us at all
which is probably why it has so made
down votes like I guess you hate just
normal but anyway it was actually just
fascinated me the most is there for five
minutes
this video just starts with her eating a
cheese stick bro silently for five
minutes
a lot of kids lately a lot of our
content has just been you eating food
good point mmm interesting rebuttal Dan
[ __ ] you Dan have we done enough to put
her in the thumbnail though or do I need
to watch longer have anything else the
video yeah well for like five minutes
I've already got her queued up in the
thumbnail ready to go you did a good job
Ian I love that I love that so much
sometime I walk out of here Ian does the
thumbnail he's art yes he's the well he
made that design I mean he's a really
time he plays himself short but he's
really talented on Photoshop mm-hmm I
think he's just a talent all-around he
doesn't give himself enough credit I
think he's an artistic eye and he's very
talented
I think I appreciate that thank you well
I mean it but that was the soundbite
he's very talented
like he kind of blows me away wait
what's that really sound what's that was
saying Zach was saying nice things about
Ian sigh I do want to allow that Jack oh
I was just saying he is very talented
with the photoshopping yeah he's awesome
we love you in and and in you didn't
really know Photoshop in the beginning
right not really I didn't really know a
lot I know how to like use the lasso
tool that's all you need it's so funny
on Photoshop everyone has their own way
of doing stuff and like you maybe know
like 10% of the program but well I feel
that my I'm very much approached
premiere adobe premiere the same way
people always have love did me people
have often said that I'm a fantastic
editor that they're very impressed by my
edits that I'm a creative genius people
have said about me and that I really
changed the YouTube landscape with what
I did in editing but actually I don't
I'm not really a good editor and I know
very little about how to use premiere I
just I'm very good at little bits and I
use that to great effect it's all about
getting creative with it I looked at the
backdrop to this whole conversation is
just this yeah I just want I'm just
trying to get another load I just want
to knock it it was good I would eat the
[ __ ] out of that yeah wonder where that
came from where do you order that from
here maybe some description cuz actually
I'm in I'm gonna go deep I saw the bag
in the beginning let's go that's a
pretty white yeah no that's pretty much
I mean I'm putting her in thumbnails so
we might as well get the best of this
she's got water in her here oh here she
goes
come on Trisha maíam grande here what
does that say it's all Korean my um
Grande yeah I'm actually just interested
in this let's see oh that's several
that's a lot though but one person holy
[ __ ] I was like hella cheese sticks oh
my god I kind of want that oh my god
that came in loud and hot like that
cheese I kind of feel sick though it's
starting to go sour here but Zach you
watched this video what did she actually
say about us well she like vlog she
shows herself on her way to the studio
and then she does a she filmed in the
studio and then talks about it two days
later for about five minutes what did
she say she says how she really liked
the format of the show
oh nice words at the first part her
first vlog on her way to the studio she
said um that she thought you were a
troll and she was curious I was gonna go
okay but then in the post interview if
you will interviewing herself
she says she really admires you in a way
oh yeah yeah she admires me Wow
nice words from Trisha Paytas how about
that she really enjoyed it I did too I
thought it was fun really great episode
and I actually I should probably reach
out about those cheese sticks just like
hey Trisha just curious can you give me
the address of this cheese yeah so there
what I think we talked about her enough
to thumbnail to thumb what are we gonna
title it like Trisha Paytas this would
be good Trisha Paytas DMCA's our podcast
a total fabrication no that's just an
owl right Trisha Paytas hmm what's the
angle just her name just her name ooh
mysterious yeah here's another clickbait
issue well it's a real issue there's
just not that much information about it
beauty pie was robbed marzia imputed by
first of all this was their house in
Japan I didn't know that I was in Japan
that's pretty baller yeah it was their
house here we got our article the wife
of YouTube's biggest star pewdiepie let
me read this article to you guys it's
better when I read it because I can
offer comments well do you understand
article that's the content yeah that's
the joke that I make it's stupid that's
what this podcast is stupid you know
here let me read this article to you
guys marzia kelberg did I say that right
and I know he gets triggered when people
say his last name wrong killed I
actually don't know kelberg I don't
think it's like that I think it is I
think it's just kelberg Kilburg oh yeah
well doesn't mean I know how to say his
[ __ ] up Swedish last name marzia
kelberg said 9% of her valuables were
stolen by thieves who broke into her in
pewdiepie his house her Instagram story
showed she said 90% of her valuables
were taken jewelry
luxury goods and special items she was
collected I know it's very materialistic
and she should be happy with what was
left but she can't hide the shock and
sadness with it all being taken away
just like that
well I certainly empathize with her I
mean that's that did getting stolen from
is such a violation it's like I feel so
bad and I have belongings that I really
especially Marcia she like dresses
really nice and it's a big part of what
she does she puts pictures almost every
day I think we'd like her outfit and
it's always like you know pick together
really nicely she has really nice stuff
and you know I can imagine like it
really meant a lot to her and it's not
even that it's expensive or whatever
it's it takes a lot of time and effort
to collect these things yeah it's not
even probably about the money it's uh
you know things you care about so when I
saw that I felt so bad for them I mean I
just I just imagine if it happened to me
that would be so sad so sad did that's
why you leaves her shoes enough in a
fingerprint safe the only packs her when
we moved to her new house you look
packed his shoes in like a mega safe box
what you should have done those the only
thing like the only nice thing I have
I'm not scratching you dude I totally
get it I put my shoes in there too but
I'm nowhere near like her collection of
clothing and nice yeah no I heard pink
is so that's ex probably felt awful yeah
that sucks [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah she's she in poop I live in
Brighton but they recently bought a
house in Japan I didn't know they're
such weaboos dude that's crazy I know
they're in Japan a lot but damn it's not
the first time the couple said they had
issues with privacy yada yada yada you
guys don't know that so so condolences
to the great
marzia kelberg Kilburg
sooo not like she'll burn shell burg
maybe that sounds Jewish she'll burn
kelberg Marcia Kelly apologies to the
great Marcia on the loss of her items
and the great felix beautify her husband
on the loss of her items of which yeah
we talked about this huh oh is that I
thought it was funnier than it was and I
quickly corrected that ever happen to
you yeah yeah you overcome it yeah
Beauty pie got his house broken into
that really sucks I feel so bad Marcia
probably lost a bunch of jewelry she
probably lost like millions I was
thinking it would be nice to send them
like a care package you wanna send her
some nice stuff though I don't know what
would you send cuz send her um all right
I could think of some funny ideas funny
stuff well you want to send her
something nice cuz how can you predict
eight-way I would wear you know I can't
you could just get like some like really
designer jewelry no that's so personal
really yeah hmm I wouldn't want anyone
to buy me jewelry unless I was ain't on
the purchase to send her a card it's
just says did cards are the most Boomer
[ __ ] ever I'm sorry like nobody should
attack them for that my mom had cysts
and she gets butthurt when nobody gives
her a when you don't give her a card on
a holiday it's just a card that like you
know the Hallmark it's already
pre-written
and then they just go low I'm so proud
you love the name yeah that's the most
Boomer [ __ ] ever so you could send her a
card condolences remember remember life
is short
you'll have to enjoy every moment cook
okay
signed your favorite boomer you seem
worried that we're all lingering on this
me yeah no okay then should we talk
about it more should we move on what do
you want to do you want to move on you
guys have anything to add to the topic
there's this flooding videos to their
house water yes it's uh it's a dark day
for the kill Berg's the kill Berg's
the chill Berg's the chill bears where's
that video their house flooding then
they get back to dang Brighton and
goddamn their house is flooded I mean my
god when it rains it pours am I right
Felix
man literally Marty awaits their need
leave water as she reveals neighbor
sewage is threatening to flood house mm
that's sucks I like really sucks yeah
yeah that really sucks I mean like
genuinely she said their garden is all
they gotta get out of England dude [ __ ]
that place it's all rainy and [ __ ]
I didn't rain here ever we had to reseed
our grass because he just died cuz it
doesn't ever rain is it really oh that's
exciting it's not it's about this I
swear to god dude yeah like yeah I like
rain not this much though she said I'm
just praying it doesn't rain again and
she's taking buckets of water that poor
girl
I do I feel bad I people may think
probably just because I am kind of
deadpan and I'm goofing around and you
don't know if I'm kidding or not I am
not kidding I do feel bad for them I
just want to make that very clear do i
do I do
oh no Cody I'm apology I guess you don't
need to apologize yet people get
sensitive about PewDiePie though so I
don't know let's see how they respond
but I am being genuine I feel awful yeah
I feel over there jeweler was stolen I
feel awful that their house is flooded I
mean it's really
unfortunate and inconvenient and
terrible and it just feel a probe sure
feels really bad mm-hmm I'm gonna send
him a condolence card condolences okay
let's put together with a piece with a
slice a ham
how would surprise him a slice of ham in
the card mailed across the ocean I don't
because it's a shock because usually as
a kid you want to see a cheque or cash
that is pretty boomer joke right there I
feel like stop you know what I'm getting
offended by the Boomer [ __ ] who just
called me a Boomer just you know yeah
you know you don't know what to expect
with me I'm that crazy slice of ham in
the card yeah because they're probably
famished
[Laughter]
probably famished it's fresh they're
hungry they're starving because of all
the tragedy in their life this is for
you I'm not here you sure you want to
send two slices ahem no have your fancy
way all the sudden your CEO you're
sitting two slices of ham EULA you've
changed all right I feel like a Boomer
let's go peloton god this this is taking
forever this episode how long we've been
going to 23 so it's been come for a
little over an hour and a half okay and
who else we haven't thumbnail yeah well
we got two people so far so and then
Olivia Jade is probably the one right
yeah she's locked and loaded
hold on yes I see what you're skipping
here I've been looking forward to this
all up no I'm kidding around I'm gonna
do everything damn god you talk about
the peloton yet no no by the way
I was so proud of this nickname I
thought of him and danced me in it being
a dick cuz he knows I was proud of it
it's like why is he sleeping ja he
should be sloppy joe like the sandwich
because he's always doing gaffes sloppy
joe biden that's good it is beautiful
thank you I guess let's skip the peloton
Ethan bought a peloton let's come back
to it cuz we're already on the topic got
a stick saw you got to go down a path
stay the course strikes it Joe Biden is
the god of cringe we've we've dubbed him
the new god of cringe now before I get
into you know let's just no let's get
into it
Biden served as a lifeguard as a young
man then called the prices run park pool
and said he was honored to see it
renamed in his honor Joseph R Biden
senior Aquatic Centre is he a senior is
Joe Biden a senior no I mean I mean I
know he's old but because why does it
what do they call it Joseph Joseph Biden
senior Oh as in is there Joe Biden Jr I
get what you're saying
I've never heard of Joe I only know of
hunter the one that does crack and stuff
if you think he does get actively doing
crack that's true you might be I don't
know he was just a few years ago well
anyway no Biden on what could only be
described as the greatest clip of all
time should understand and to get hot I
got along it I got hairy legs that turn
that that that that that turned about
blonde in the Sun and the kids used to
come up and reach in the pool and rub my
leg down
so it was training that watch the hair
come back up again
they look at it so I learned about
roaches I learned about kids jumping on
my lap and I've loved kids jumping on my
lap and I tell you what okay
can you man why I'm gonna give him a mic
to say that what is he trying to say
well like I'm happy for you you'll be
happy to know that I transcribed it I
had Dan transcribe it for me you want to
hit me with some music what's the mood
for for this oh come on you guys what do
you mean you didn't ask for music Joe
Biden patriotic music no it's like
creepy or think [ __ ] okay while you
guys pull that up I'll show you Joe
Biden sucking on his wife's finger fared
it to a sloppy joe the video kind of
exonerates yeah the video isn't as bad
it's weird though even in the video well
I'll I'll show it I don't know how to it
happens so fast I don't know how they
get such a high quality picture I know
it's like a perfect shot of him sucking
on his wife's finger man it's amazing
[Music]
okay so now here's the other thing I
wanted to bring to you guys attention
he's on a tour in Iowa right now to drum
up support it's called the no malarkey
tour bro
hila goes what's malarkey people don't
even know what malarkey is nobody said
malarkey in like 50 years we said
malarkey since the last time he said
malarkey I'm pretty sure it's why it's
in reference to that do you remember he
oh here's a malarkey quote it was in one
of the debates I want to say the the
2012 wait was that a big moment for him
they said malarkey sort of what Joe
Biden malarkey pays attention to the
vice presidential debate anyways it was
in a vice presidential debate against I
want to say Paul Ryan I think it was the
election here it is we're in business
now yeah with the respect to Afghanistan
the 2014 deadline we agree with a 2014
transition but what we also want to do
is make sure that we're not projecting
weakness abroad and that's what's
happening here this then Ghazi issue all
right would be a tragedy in and of
itself but importantly it's indicative
of a broader problem and that is what we
are watching in our TV screens is the
unraveling of the Obama foreign policy
which is making the board mark more
chaos less safe I just want to talk to
you about right in the middle of the
crisis Governor Romney and you're
talking about this again tonight talked
about the weakness I get a drum roll
zone for the malarkey moment really
appropriate you need the contact we need
to build up let's get a drum roll on
that same day the Obama administration
had the exact same position let's recall
the big disavow there
Kylee same position but it's never too
early to speak up snorts outrageous we
should have spoken out right away when
the Green Revolution was up and starting
when the more we're attacking today we
should not have called the shara sod a
reformer when he was turning his Russian
provided guns on his own people we
should all the anticipation is palpable
perceived for individual rights and we
should not be imposing these devastating
defense cuts because what that says when
we equivocate on our values when we show
that we're cutting our own defense it
makes us more weak it projects weakness
is a much more willing to test us
they're more brazen they're attacking
our respect that's a bunch of malarkey
what's this big moment
Wow
okay so I mean that's a pretty weak
point to run with if that's the whole
explanation but the dude is going on a
no malarkey tour and he's getting
clowned on big time dude look at his bus
no more he's trying to appeal to young
people and by the way here's the the
famous number 303 300 to Joe 303 3 you
had to define malarkey on the bus they
think they're being funny
no they literally yeah but someone
thought this was funny oh I think it was
I think it was Joe Biden's uh grandpa
who put this campaign together from from
heaven
this man is helpless Democratic
frontrunner so malarkey means insincere
or foolish dog yeah malarkey is such a
weird word yeah because it hasn't been
said since nineteen fifty did nobody
says it it's like an old-timey word
malarkey it's like you're my larkey you
don't want to say [ __ ] so you're
trying to be polite in front of the
ladies hmm because women aren't to say
it's that kind of mentality we got music
for the transcription he's got music I
don't know what it is
so ela I'm going to for you I'm going to
read back his comments transcribed for
your listening pleasure so that you can
decipher what it is he was trying to say
so Zack if you would please and by the
way you know I sit on the stand and I
get hot I got a lot of uh I got hairy
legs that turn that uh that that that
that turned blonde and the Sun and the
kids used to come up and reach in a pool
of rub my legs down so it was straight
and then they watched the hair come back
up again
and I look at him so I learned about
roaches learned about kids jumping on my
lap and I've loved kids jumping on my
lap and I tell you what amazing
thank you you got I started to sound
like um what's-his-name in whoo
why can I not remember his name what
movie the show where he plays the
politician and always the guy that was a
soundbite hey Kevin Spacey good one Ian
I sounded like Kevin Spacey mm-hmm
that's interesting because he was the
vice president yep you're channeling him
a little bit well congratulations to Joe
Biden on being the presidential
frontrunner sloppy sloppy joe is blond
hair on his legs and kids were playing
it's a weird anecdote my dude and he
calls them roaches yeah he called a
bunch of black kid roaches that seems
racial to me no it was in reference to
another part of the story I feel like it
had to vincas that would be a huge story
he said so I learned about roaches this
that clip actually was from a longer
speech that a different part of it had
already gone viral the whole wait what
it's the contact is there was another
anecdote in that where he got into a
fight with a kid named corn pop and like
and he became his friend and he had like
a long rambling anecdote about corn pop
yeah and that had already gone viral and
I'm surprised like this other part of it
didn't at the time that's like come back
around yeah
the enemies of Joe Biden have just been
like yeah looking for anything still
like conceding a little bit this is a
sloppy joe by the way you uh so do you
like the nickname more knowing oh really
yeah
Wow that's the name the sloppy joe is
this is a ground beef in between two
hamburger buns that's awful
yes it's Deewar sandwich probably ever
don't want that again it's old-timey
just like sloppy joe himself over a
sloppy coffee cup of joe no this it's
called a sloppy joe cuz it's I mean it's
just for putress yeah it's like it's a
it's like a deconstructed hamburger
that's worse and it's all saucy like
it's just I think it's distinctly an
American thing to like I don't they come
on where else are you gonna find it yeah
exactly
cuz it's not like steak I feel like in
other parts of the world they would be
like it would be like chopped up steak
or like zero or something but this is
just ground beef bro what's saw it's
just awful Zach like sloppy joe I'm sure
of it I've actually had 100 my mom used
to make the animal man it was raised and
sometimes growing up too I would did not
know Florida - the sloppy joe even even
as a kid you know like you would think
like a hamburger bun some ground beef
it's hard to go wrong with that that
looks like a kid's nightmare this was
always on my school cafeteria menu Oh
sloppy joe it's like and the sauce that
they mix it and ruins it like if it was
just ground beef and bun I think I like
it more but they mix it in just like
terrible sauce or even sometimes just
ketchup Worcestershire Worcestershire
just pure moisture that's pretty
heavy-duty that's like the main
flavoring you want to read the cat the
recipe
it says ketchup tomato sauce and brown
sugars oh my god it's just too saucy bro
let's look up a sloppy joe recipe well
so good the top-rated imagine somebody
outside is actually making sloppy dare
on 2020 the best homemade sloppy joe
I don't want to actually want a
low-rated one okay I don't want a
gourmet sloppy joe
you know what I mean man which weird the
company that makes the like
standard-issue sloppy joe sauce or
whatever man which wears manwich manager
what a nightmare
who do you eat something called a man
which sounds like you're eating a dick
man which it's like when you put your
dick in a hot dog bun a manwich
so here you go you guys want to know the
recipe hey me olive oil tomato paste
Worcestershire sauce you know your
sloppy joe they'll give you that tomato
sauce ketchup brown sugar apple cider
vinegar
this sounds gourmet yeah but I'm sure
it's awful huh that's [ __ ] awful dude
get out of here
good nickname right yeah thank you Joe
it's very clever that you thought that
up and you didn't even know if the
sloppy joe sandwich was Dan was goofing
on me he was giving you credit for
thinking of my brilliant nickname for
smoking Joe Biden Olivia Jade is back in
the news she's back on YouTube
you guys remember may remember Olivia
Jade she was the daughter actually a
somewhat famous youtuber daughter of
Lorrie Lachlan best known for her role
in full house she she was one of a dozen
people charged in March in connection
with a multi-million dollar college
admissions scheme actually her story was
the best one the the indictment against
Laughlin and her husband alleged that
they paid half a million dollars
disguised as a donation that means it
was tax-deductible to those [ __ ]
an order to get her daughter into the
USC but here's the best part they faked
that she was on the women's rowing team
and she has never trained or
participated or planned in being on the
rowing team and if I recall correctly
they did like fake photo shoots and
photo shops to make them look like they
were rowers means out ray
and so she was the one that was involved
in that just a little update before we
watched the daughter's video her parents
rejected a plea deal accidentally back
up
her parents surrendered of federal
authorities in Los Angeles and March and
their subsequent appearance in the
United States Court in Los Angeles
Lachlan and Gian how do you say this gee
I gr newly Asiana Lee it's like a
italiana I forget about a sloppy joke
come on oh yeah get in huh do you think
sloppy joes an Italian dish can you
imagine getting that nice and tight
Broco Tula Bernardin three-michelin-star
sloppy joe deconstructed they were
released on a bond of one-million
dollars and were permitted to retain
their passports and travel outside the
United States as long as they informed
the court they rejected a plea deal
including the charge of which included
the charge of money laundering that
required because I guess probably
because of the they pretended that it
was a charity and wrote it off can you
imagine like throwing that on top not oh
no that's crazy just the fake donation
alone is uh is a crime so that's money
laundering and and they were going to be
required to each spend two years in
prison bro but they did they rejected
the plea deal and pleaded not guilty
then Lachlan regretted regrets not
taking the plea deal and was angered at
her husband for suggesting that they
reject the plea deal as he feared it
would ruin their careers too late for
that dumb dumb in October of this year
federal prosecutors said that Lachlan is
now facing additional charges in the
College Admission cheating scandal US
attorney Andrew Welling said Lachlan is
now being charged with conspiring to
commit federal program bribery to
facilitate their children's admission in
exchange for the bribe employees at the
University allegedly does
needed the defendants children as
athletic recruits with little or no
regard for their athletic abilities dude
they're so fat I cannot believe I acted
the plea deal they're gonna go to prison
well they are criminals
I mean basically when you when you do a
fake donation to a charity for $500,000
you're stealing a lot of money from the
government from not paying taxes mm-hmm
cuz she's I'm sure it's high tax bracket
so when you donate five hundred thousand
dollars it's actually just buying
something for your daughter
you're basically ripping off the
government $250,000 because it's not
deductible what are you saying something
to me down I just was it five hundred or
fifty thousand no five hundred bro they
they paid five hundred thousand and they
disguised it as a donation that's the
best part
so they're [ __ ] so anyway her daughter
that was about eight months ago
how Domas her daughter doesn't need to
pay half a million dollars to get her
into this I know man
just go to it just go somewhere else or
don't or be a better student you idiot
you're on YouTube just do that No
so here she is by the way this was
number one trending all day is almost
like YouTube was trying to dunk on her
because so many people didn't know who
she was or near like the video is so
short and pointless that it was just if
it was a a bonanza in the comments
section so here and by the way she was
trying to say that she didn't know but
obviously evidences come out I've even
heard rumors and I may be thinking of a
different case so don't quote me on this
or you know off the record but I think
they were possibly discussing of
charging her with something for being
complicit yeah really
because she was in on the scheme to
pretend to be an athlete Wow she was
saying she didn't know about it that she
didn't know she did that but I was a
possible she didn't know but how they
were pretending that she was an athlete
bro and also she's got if she's a shitty
student how do you get in USC that's a
good school yeah
like old man I got a mom I failed every
class I have a 2.0 GPA good news honey
you got into USC anyway whatever here's
her video it's still number nine
trending and this came out like three
days ago their try YouTube is trying to
ruin this poor girl's life by the way
when it first came out it had like 80%
likes and I was like what maybe than 90%
and all the comments were like her
parents bought likes on the video but
now it has slowly deteriorated so here
we go she says hi again so buck love
y'all really long time and as much as I
wish I could talk about all of this she
lit candles for the video mm-hmm and
there's a ton of jump cuts to say like
nothing because I know I'm not gonna
pause this it's something that needs to
be addressed it's just unfortunately
which is also why I didn't know exactly
when I should come back to YouTube but
the reason for that is just because I'm
legally not allowed to speak on anything
not legally
first of all ear you could say whatever
you want you're not oh there's no wha
this is you can't talk about it
your lawyers probably told you not to
talk about right not legally what does
that mean there's America lady it's not
Chinese should I come back to YouTube
right now because I it's been so long
and I actually really really miss it
like I genuinely miss filming I feel
like a huge part of me it's just no the
same I was a crazy couple in it I mean
and to be fair that's something that a
lot of youtubers do so watch this cut a
huge part of me is just not the same
like mitts like though she didn't
pronounce finish pronounciating the word
this is something that I'm really
passionate about it's something I really
like to do not talk for two minutes
without jump cutting it at 22
like seven or eight months like well if
I can't talk about it is there a point
in coming back
there's not one chump cut in this whole
podcast ela we and me just talking for
10 minutes of the camera about how I
wish I could say something when I really
can't
that's what you're doing that's like to
move with my trying to be in a selfish
way it's so hard cuz I'm not trying to
like make this about me
or like how I've been because that means
it's not the point of this though I'm
terrified to make this video one and to
come back I know that I also want to
start taking smaller steps in the right
direction for people that I've been
dealing and asking me we're all the
story is I've missed you guys so much
marlis don't [ __ ] hate to get into
college that's definitely not the moral
I think can't believe this story I just
cannot believe it that's so good yeah
apparently like according to some
articles that I'm seeing
she didn't fully know what her parents
were doing that is bad I knew it was
anything wrong well you know they say
the apple doesn't fall far from the tree
if the parents think it's exact she
wants back into school back into USC
she's worried now that without it
education her life will just be
completely maybe should the ladies
listen to yourself that's I'm so funny
that she wants to go back oh that's the
best that's so great that's so rich but
ultimately this is a failure of
parenting yeah I honestly like if your
parents she's a young kid she's in high
school if the parents are like oh honey
this is norm by the way they paid for
her and her sister not just her
the five hundred thousand oh so it was a
bargain yeah I want to get one for you
good deal there was a promotion during
the holidays
you know as a high school student she's
probably like honey it's normal don't
worry I'm famous I'm rich this is what
everybody does yeah okay mom but but she
was a little raspy in the video okay I
feel like she was like I don't want to
cry because that would be like typical
typical but I want to come back but I
want to look all emotional so she was
doing actually say anything because the
lawyers are actually vetted this video
there's nothing left
well let's go to the comments I love
that she wants to go back Oh
moral the story be humble you're not
above anyone you are not above
forgiveness and you're certainly not
above mistakes yall already know I
didn't press play went straight to the
comments I did that too well to her a
great credit she did not disable
comments everything in life is worth
more when you have to earn it
well that's a true statement the college
should say on a rejection letter sorry
full house ooh there's a supportive
comment I can hear and feel the pain in
her voice she's afraid to talk to us on
YouTube and she's asking us for
permission to be on YouTube I support
you
Wow Olivia Jade Jean Marie Perez someone
said her arms look so skinny must be
from all the rowing anyway we have a we
have a collection of the funniest
comments here that we've collected I had
a lot of laughs it's not about me talks
about how hard it's been for I mean that
was why would you even go down that
angle it's all right or what is it about
Olivia hi again Thanos I don't even know
who you are can you unpack that joke for
me Dan it's a reference to the last
movie did Danna say I don't even know
who you are
to the [ __ ] character that nobody
gives a [ __ ] about wait what yeah which
one Elizabeth Olsen right Scarlet Witch
there you go
uh-huh that comes up to her mole badass
I'll kick your ass and he doesn't even
know who she is
oh that's awesome so if Thanos dissed
her zero self-awareness zero shame and
the end zero college degree I'm Connie
this morning actually her parents were
my childhood watching for us was great
and then this oh that's not funny that's
just genuine there's no point in me
talking to the camera she nailed it next
video idea jail to her who did her mom
bribe to like this vid basically the
video hey guys okay thank you so much
for watching yeah I can't wait for this
tutorial on how to dress for a court
hearing that's pretty good I should I
feel bad make tossing her I do feel bad
but also it's mostly her parents mm-hmm
but God are they shitty people I mean to
just actually pay so much money on top
of the so on top of the bribe the tax
deduction the phonetic donation to
charity is the perfect icing on the cake
of total douchebaggery and apparently
they have a lot of evidence of
everything like mmm I saw in articles
that there's no ego at all and then they
go I love that he goes I'm not accepting
the plea deal cuz it will ruin our
career prosecutors don't like when you
don't accept the plea deal mmm
well there you have it Olivia Jade is
back and I'm looking forward to our next
vlog which will be heavily looked at by
lawyers how rich are they that's a lot
of cheddar Throwdown on a like half a
million bucks just to throw down on your
shitty dumb kid to go to USC also USC
ain't ain't cheap either but it's a lot
less than half a million bucks
how much is Laurie I mean she's pretty
famous though looked at that full house
net worths six million I mean what it's
got any more than that
it's Massimo the dad oh oh
Massimo's rich he did all it's like the
target errand oh oh [ __ ] I didn't know
that like all of like the Target brand
clothes so they're they're a power
couple I'm mostly him I mean she was on
a sitcom she's famous actress what has
she done besides full house well it's a
big show that's one of the biggest shows
ever I guess what have you done I'm on
the biggest show ever
right now the h3 podcasts sir drew see
right answer thank you I cannot believe
that they did that these guys said these
guys to rejected a plea deal because it
would ruin their career breath look at
them look at that though aren't they
both possibly going to oh yeah
everybody's [ __ ] everybody
oh here's the extra daughter so she's
getting all the [ __ ] I guess because
she's a youtuber but she also fig being
on the rowing team bro can you imagine
if I like pretended to be like a power
lifter or some [ __ ] the room
why would you do that why would you why
would that acai just can't get over it
okay so much just like actually get into
the school I know like how like so even
if it worked and she and she is like
honey don't worry this is just what rich
people do it's like you are setting your
child up for a lifetime of apparently
she did any other California schools it
was a [ __ ] awful sooner I got into
you CSC
which basically if you breathe they
accept you there do you know how bad you
have to be of a student to not get into
UCSC bro that's other and then even
below that is UC Irvine people don't
even know that was a UC sorry to
everyone who goes there but you know I'm
right it's actually really hard to get
in those schools now mmm I guess I got
him by the neck the skin of my teeth
because I only got into UC Santa Cruz
and UC Irvine so I assumed that they
were but I was so relieved I was like
thank God did I got accepted into
something you know but what shitty
parents what kind of lesson is that the
teacher kid yeah
well now they ruined their life
potentially all of them yeah oh she's
all stuck she's looking good for the
court hearing I can't get over it
oh my god they're crazy look at this
photo
I'm over it Dan's over it
you can use ela to tell me you're all
right I'm over it
actually we should probably wrap it up
because well we hit all the big boys
Pete Davidson makes people sign one mil
ago our NDA who go to a stand-up show we
all agreed he's a [ __ ] for doing that
right Dan definitely
actually by watching this episode the H
Street podcast you are we have to agree
to never say anything bad about me or to
ever call me boomer a billion a 1
billion dollar contract if you don't
accept the terms you are free to close
the video right now but if you watch
past this point you agree to one
trillion dollar lawsuit if you ever call
me a boomer what is it in Scientology
you agree for I think it's a billion
years a billion years
yeah it's a billion-year contract I'm
not sure that's legally binding by the
way nor it by the way is Pete Davidson's
[ __ ] nd a legally binding it's such
a [ __ ] dumb ass
first of all there's no way any court
would enforce this NDA I don't think so
$1,000,000 yeah saw a lot of legal
opinions weighing in on it and saying
it's totally bogus all right yeah it's
just stupid it's just a scare tactic but
it's like dude you know everyone is
operate yeah we everyone knows it's
tough out there for comedians
right everybody's playing by the same
rules you're the only dude who can't
handle someone I posted the agreement
yeah and then at the top it says in
short by signing this you're agreeing to
not discuss any details of the show
anything about your experience of this
event period I just thought you're not
even allowed to say you liked it so what
I thought was funny that sounds like he
wrote that yeah like the period that's
not legal
that's not legalese I thought it would
be funny to start making up rumors like
I was at his show and he did something
outrageous but nobody could confirm or
deny it cuz they all signed NDA's I
wanted to tweet out like damn I just saw
Pete Davidson's stand up him I am
risking a million dollars to tell you
this but it was good except for he just
started screaming the n-word and was
like super shocked it was super
unexpected it wasn't funny at all
and everybody stormed out and just like
start making up rumors that nobody can
dispute well you might get served
but yes serve me because it's called
comedy [ __ ] is called a parody it's not
it's not it's not a slander if it's a
joke I know that because I was sued for
slander and won I was sued for slander
you know you like that [ __ ] come up with
the sum of $1,000,000
he's being a douche you just a mount
that sounds intimidating but to me it
makes it sound completely incredible I
guess most most common people who aren't
familiar with this kind of thing would
just be like ooh spooky I don't want
deal with that but the thing that most
people don't realize when confronted
with like this kind of thing when it
feels very scary like I had the same
reaction when I would get copyright
strikes on YouTube most people get it's
both it's all [ __ ] and posturing
it's nothing this thing is worth isn't
worth the paper it's printed on it's a
total [ __ ]
he goes individuals agree that any
breach of this agreement will cause
company and its affiliates and business
partners incalculable damage you douche
Inc so you're saying your own bit will
cause you incalculable damage and I was
like unclear because he just calculated
it it was that he does instead he
doesn't want people to steal his jokes
or he's afraid because it's like work in
progress and you've got to work your
material in front of audience yeah I
mean oh there's nothing of value there
to steal then I mean there's that but
also it's just like I mean unless like
you said unless you do like a Michael
Richards and just completely go off like
nobody nobody actually cares about this
well it's like no one get mad at you for
like half a day actually and nobody
cares yes right he caught [ __ ]
he caught [ __ ] for calling he went to a
show and bombed and was calling college
students like douche bags and stuff and
I guess he's had an experience but he
called them privileged little [ __ ]
because they were recording on their
cell phones which again leads me back to
like i guess it's maybe it's more about
stealing jokes no cancel no it's the
cancelled thing it says here in a
contract that work and probably
understand that it's a work in progress
or something yeah you're heard says um
as yet unreleased creative content yeah
individual is or will be a guest of
company at a performance event for the
purpose of viewing a work in progress
see it's just weak it's like come on you
got to be brave to do community like you
just gotta you got to just do it like I
want to say about Pete Davidson
is that his name Pete Davidson that um
I'm gonna say about Pete Davidson that I
don't find him to be funny and I think
that he's just [ __ ] a lot of famous
girls and that's the only reason
anyone's ever met thought even thought
about him before like before he dated
Selena you got
sorry what's her name uh Ariana sorry in
before he dated Ariana nobody [ __ ]
uttered his name well that's I mean I
don't think he was a minor cast member
on SNL yeah I mean to get on this I know
you want to go through okay but you're
not telling me there's not a be a lot of
berate oh for sure
a lot of terrible I'm just saying he
before he before he was dating Ariana
was like mainstream and then he dated uh
this guy must have like a golden dipped
[ __ ] or something cuz like he dated
Ariana then he dated some old cougar I
swear no he did he was [ __ ] was older
than him no she was like fifty bro I'm
telling you we got to get a history of
Pete Davidson Arianna City is a massive
penis there yeah but well there you go
but was it gold devil health is a gold
dipped I like it
Pete Davidson history of dating let's
see complete dating history Larry
David's daughter oh right so here we've
got the whole thing
yeah Larry David's daughter that was
before I guess that was I feel like he's
kind of moving up up in the dating world
it's kind of like trashy in a way cuz
he's like Dom Larry David's daughter who
was very cute by the way
which is unexpected from I mean Larry
David is not a very cute person I mean
she's pretty so that they the one that
you're talking about is 46 years old
yeah and he's like 22 you don't think
that's a big age gap EULA if that was a
guy wouldn't you be so Paige
no I'm he's 26 okay is that not a creepy
weird age gap yeah yeah if that was a
reverse age what would you think yeah
yeah but ariana grande and then go
we find the older person being the
creepy one yeah sure for him whatever
kate beckinsale dude that's crazy man
and then I don't know who this is
Margaret quale
once upon a time a Hollywood star oh she
was the psycho girl okay
and now most recently this is Cindy
Crawford's daughter I was like god damn
dude just what is going on with this guy
yeah he's probably got he's probably got
it his dick is probably gilded he's just
got game or a gilded with [ __ ]
harpies you know I'm saying no I'm
kidding these are all very clean ladies
he's probably got HPV at least do you
find him attractive I mean I'm just
genuinely curious because I mean he's
like tall and slender and fit and dress
as well so I get that and he's famous
that helps a lot but and he's like
damaged goods his dad his dad died in
9/11 which is like X Factor bro that's
very [ __ ] well I really don't know
what to say about all of this well
comment you're the only female in the
room I cannot I like I cannot explain
these this record of dating that's
pretty crazy mmm I don't know so you're
saying he's he's pretty good but not as
good as you you don't understand the
that he's just hitting a three-pointer
like with every shot yeah but you're
saying that he's pretty good like on a
scale of one to ten what would you rate
him and fever including all factors I
don't know I honestly don't know much
about him I don't even know I don't
watch SNL well he's making people sign
an NDA to watch him to stand up
I feel like that makes him less cool
doesn't it yes that makes him lesser I
don't like that I feel he's got to get a
less attractive girlfriend after that
he's gonna have to date like a six next
time then maybe you can move back up to
like eight or nine any thoughts from the
gallery
he has no pizza experience okay you can
always say that about definitely doesn't
have any pizzas Ariane's oh I want to
say before we leave I want to say
something this is a message to Jonah
Hill
can you play romantic music now I saw
this note and that was very play
romantic music before I get into this
fuse this is a message to Jonah Hill me
and my wife for driving in the parking
lot of Starbucks in Brentwood
we saw you getting out with a coffee
from Starbucks and you looked at us for
a minute as if to say to yourself how do
I know them and we caught eyes and we
stared at each other for a good five
seconds of intense eye contact I knew
you and I think you knew me but you
didn't know until maybe I I left and I
want to say I want to get shot I want to
reach out to you Jonah Hill and say that
I have not stopped thinking about that
intense eye contact since light just
blew out the electricity's in the air
could you see that light literally just
exploded yeah Wow the electricity is in
the air Jonah Hill I love you I love you
work you looked great he looks confident
you look swagged out what was that movie
he made recently mid-90s or whatever mid
nineteen I didn't see that but I heard
it was very good but I do like your
acting a lot you're a brilliant actor I
love doing Moneyball I won't even say
super bad because that's just so boomers
say
super bad that's obvious and you're such
a different guy now just so much better
than that Netflix show that I really
liked what was oh yeah the one with the
Emily maniac maniac Wow incredible when
I'm trying to say Jonah Hill is that I
think that we connected on a spiritual
level when we caught eyes and you looked
at me if to say it do I know them front
did I go to school with them
have I seen them somewhere have I met
them somewhere no it is I the greatest
entertainers have lived possibly the
greatest comedic minds ever graced this
planet Earth you don't know it but
you're influenced by my comedy because
everyone around you was influenced by my
comedy and so what I would like to say
is I'm gonna put this up as a highlight
because I know you probably don't well
you definitely don't want your show
because you would have flagged down my
card told me to stop it's in the
presence of greatness you act out of you
act out rashly
which he did and so I hand out this hand
to Jonah Hill and I say as my wife sits
before me that I will leave my wife for
you know I saw a connection I feel
betrayed and I from one chubby bearded
man to another I want to if I want to
collaborate that job he looks great I
shouldn't call Shelby he looks fantastic
he's still a little chubby he didn't
lose everything like me except I'm he's
on his way out I'm on my way in but I
hope that we can meet somewhere in the
middle and kind of collaborate maybe
he's got tips for me my problem is he
does Taekwondo and [ __ ] I was like oh
don't win you go dude I don't do [ __ ] I
got an exercise I'm trying to lose
weight and I gotta get I got on a bike I
got a peloton bike
keep it quiet whoa I'm still willing in
it
do you think this is gonna work is he
gonna reach out Joan hell if you want to
reach me to collaborate if you want to
come on the show if you want maybe we
could write a movie together you want to
write a script I'll be your leading man
you can direct and write it I'll be your
leading man we can collaborate on the
writing you could be my leading man I'll
write a script but the point is from one
comedy genius to another when it's just
an extra an extras in the background
that's not the kind of connection I had
I felt leaning man vibes when we caught
eyes I was so enamored that I pulled to
the side and Gila went in to get coffee
and we just got a new car and I scraped
the wheel so [ __ ] bad dude was such a
disappointment
I scraped that [ __ ] and there's people
sitting out front and the Starbucks and
was a spectacle they were looking at me
and then I knew it was bad when I looked
to the side and I saw people watching me
it's not that ball I [ __ ] up my car I
know it that's either that's not the
point though the point is that I think
he might be looking on Craigslist of at
lost connections missed connections
for me are you you for me you know what
miss connections are that's this when
you catch eyes with somebody at like
ROVs or Trader Joe's and then you go to
Craigslist and you go you were wearing
the blue dress and I saw you in the
veggie aisle and I think that we
connected
reach out that's what I'm doing I think
you were in a Range Rover I'm not
entirely sure
I won't mention my car cuz I don't want
people to know what I Drive should I
convention it's a Model X I just got it
it's a nice car I like it a lot why
would you mention Heath Caron not yours
yeah I know that's why I felt that it's
like I outed him and then not me
yeah how we just got it like a week ago
and I bought the tire up and I got these
crazy rims like the crazy ones the big
black ones it looks sick and I just I
scratched this [ __ ] out of him shame but
is worth it to meet you
so that's the wraps it up today for the
a true podcast who knows I mean he might
reach out to me well how should I reach
out you'll find me I follow you on
Instagram CMU thank you no he's not
maybe I'm pretty famous like kind of a
big deal he obviously but you Dan
imagine him watching this clip out of
context yeah he would be like - that guy
rules he'd know but he knows who I am
because he had the recognition of like
did I go to school with him did this
happen after you [ __ ] up your car no
after yeah this happened before
right before same parking lot okay saw
him and we were driving through and then
I was like oh [ __ ] that's Jonah Hill
yeah he walked right in front of the car
and he looked at us for a long long time
I think I don't know like this guy's
gonna try and talk to me no I was in my
car Dan he recognized us I've seen that
look people look at me like it happens
all the time because they they're not
fans but they've seen maybe something
I've done right and they go how do I
know I know that guy how do I know him
he's probably seen vapenation Dan he's
probably seen I mean let's be honest
I've made a lot of good videos on
YouTube millions of views billions
actually
so chances that he hadn't seen me is
less then it's more like the dad sings
yeah this is over well just wrap it up
I'm waiting for you I'm over it I'm over
it you want written the show no I did
last time you want me to leave no I'll
leave right now
you just tell me if you're over it and
for those reasons I'm out so Jonah Hill
I'd like to say that I love you I want
to be with you I want to collaborate
with you I want to hands with you
I want to comb my Amster your beard I
want to go belly to belly with you one
hairy two that I'm about from another
I want to go tip to tip we will see you
back again Saturday
no one is watching right go ahead and it
you're doing good
no one is watching and aspyn's but if
you do watch please leave a comment too
bad you can [ __ ] up his car on the
first week feel really bad for him
sad face chewy brigade are fans to go
contact John he'll go ahead you're
ending the show don't tell Joe Neville
about this
whatever you do go Eddie look there's a
problem like how do you end it exactly
you know what the you so exactly goodbye
like a safety word okay goodbye
everybody
damn so are you gonna awful everybody
thanks for sticking around through all
this we really appreciate you remember
to go to HT HT shop and pick up some
fresh and merch also teddy fresh is
mostly sold out but I believe that sale
is a mr. chance full price but still we
very much appreciate you we will see you
on Saturday and Tata
[Music]